it's another march of marches in
pakistan pro and anti-government rallies
are happening in major cities although
the election is scheduled for next year
in the last three and a half years
inflation has skyrocketed to double
digits the rupee has lost its value and
campaign promises remain unfulfilled
adding to prime minister imran khan's
woes is the perception that pakistan's
powerful military establishment no
longer supports him
han is trying to muster support as a
vote of no confidence gets closer
his coalition government's slim majority
is at stake as allies and some party mps
are indicating they will vote against
him
opposition parties are negotiating terms
with disgruntled government mps and
allies those who vote against him imran
khan wants to ban them from taking part
in politics for life calling them
corrupt thieves and turncoats
pakistan needs to decide if they will
let the conspiring slaves who have taken
billions of rupees from abroad be
successful
he should then shut up on these things
incendiary statements have real-life
consequences says
a member of the national assembly who
spoke out against his governing pti
party's failures
he says his children have been
threatened in addition to receiving
thousands of messages of hate and
profanity i joined
pta because
of imran khan's saying and then he said
that in his own manifesto also that
there will be an accountability across
the board
he will not be having any corrupt
minister i will go against
two things
a
for hate speech second allegations by
the prime minister of pakistan
any everybody who have
named us
the minister for information does not
believe the prime minister's speeches
are inflammatory people are very angry
on you know
how can you tolerate such people who
will sell their
vote for for money there's a history of
horse trading in pakistan
10 years ago the minister was defending
arsenal izadari the former leader of the
pakistan people's party or ppp
chaudhary has changed three parties in
the last decade but he says allegiances
can be changed before elections and
those who are not happy with the
government's performance should resign
under article 63a of the constitution
you cannot vote against your party i
should be going back to my people and
you know explaining them that this is
the reason i'm changing the party and
then
i can change the party i cannot stab my
party in the back
and in the murky politics of pakistan
nuralim won't declare if he will vote
against han i am a member of a pti
let's go to the parliament on that day
we will decide whether to vote or
for or against
they say there are no permanent enemies
or friends in politics but if imran khan
wants to become the first prime minister
to complete his five-year term he's
gonna need friends who last a little bit
longer